c'est le jour j au festival de montoir
le moment où tous les participants
artistes et bénévoles se rencontrent
pour passer une semaine ensemble
l'apéro de l'amitié une coutume à
montoir depuis 43 ans
qu'est ce qui vous motive à participer à
ce festival ben alors mieux
regroupés entre jeunes il ya tout y est
otage en plus c'est une des meilleures
choses que véhicule ce festival il y a
des connexions on trouve plein de jeunes
gens différents
ça permet d'échanger avec d'autres
origines d'autres cultures à travers le
monde
la veille le président du festival avait
réuni tous les responsables bénévoles
qui assurent la logistique
l'intendance et les autres services pour
faire le point avec les directeurs des
groupes étrangers invités par le
festival accompagnons les groupes
en fait pour qu'ils puissent avoir un
accueil avec des locaux qui connaissent
le festival pour leur dire le programme
régler les petits problèmes du quotidien
si faire le lien aussi avec l'équipe
d'organisation et le groupe
ici le courant passe très vite outre les
300 artistes et les bénévoles qui sont
passés de 150 l'an dernier à près de 250
cette année le pari de rajeunir le
festival serait donc sur le point d'être
gagné